[Music]
all right I have a story of this man who
has absolutely no game and he refuses to
learn from his mistake it's okay
and he keeps doing the same thing even
after years even after going jail
even after getting arrested he's still
[ __ ] doing this is he stopping no or
kind of kind of yes a little bit hidden
cameras no but it's like bad game right
so it's just like maybe the way he's
trying to attract women he keeps doing
the same exact thing even though it
doesn't work mirrors on the shoe no
wearing skirts that's just to be honest
straight up perv yeah Oh guys like that
are not even trying to talk to the girl
though they're just oh he's trying to
talk some use your your body to get off
yeah so no this guy is actually trying
to like talk to the girl what is he
doing alright now this so this man I
love these stories yeah so he decided
the best way to meet women is by
slashing their tires and then go into
the rescue once you they notice that
they have a flat tire and then like he'd
be like the knight in shining if I just
kill her mother
and then comfort her she'll fall in love
hey what's the difference between that
and a girl who trips and falls in front
of you you're hurting yourself though
yeah but it's yeah one is damaging
property and yeah obviously that it's
illegal but then it's I think it's the
same concept of like let me manipulate
the situation exactly yeah but in when
the girl doesn't is just cuter oh yeah I
gotcha tired adorable
it's got Hello Kitty on the [ __ ]
handle do you need help fixing your tire
like I don't know how I'm gonna call
Ghibli for you well yeah so the reason
why this came to light again he did we
did well he did this back in 2013
damn what if it actually works that's
why it keeps doing it it doesn't it
literally does not get to actually have
like form any sort of relationship with
any of these women that he's slashing
their tires they don't even let him
barely even let him help them well I
don't know that much detail but I'll
tell you this one story so this 43 year
old woman she was shopping at a
supermarket in Japan by the way please
enjoy of course this is to pay and so
once she finished she finished shopping
she hops in her car starts driving away
but then she had to pull over because
she noticed that her driver's side rear
tire had gone completely flat so then
that's when she pulls over and then all
of a sudden this guy pulls up this 32
year old man who offered to replace her
damaged tire and so she was like whoa
this feels like deja vu what the [ __ ] oh
no the same person so he forgot that he
did it to her one year later he forgot
that he already did it
that's how fine she is though she's so
[ __ ] fine that it caught his
attention twice and he forgot she
thought that whole encounter was like
this is a really weird coincidence she I
am assuming that she didn't bring it up
to the guy because she ended up going to
she still needed to change the tire yeah
so she she reported to the police and so
they ended ended up investigating they
saw the supermarket surveillance camera
footage and they saw that he was the one
who slashed the tire in the parking lot
right before she came out and so that's
when uhm that's when they ended up going
on Tashi Takashi Takashi like
yep cause they was yoshito yoshito
Yoshida Yoshi that's a funny name Yoshi
doh
I picture this full showing up with the
exact tire to tire so you must be hungry
and you want to go to lunch right
obviously not but no like not even for
this next fact because he keeps doing it
in the same city too like all these
years so back in 2013 it was a similar
situation where this man ended up
approaching a woman and then the woman
was like wait what and then this other
woman that she had known she was like
wait I had a similar encounter with this
dude oh my god like he just goes around
the whole town slashing tires by the way
like everyone has a car in Japan so I'm
assuming that people that do have cars
or it's a town so it's a small town and
everyone knows each other exactly cuz
like when I heard cars in supermarket
I'm like oh he's in like he's not in the
city yeah yeah yes is in the city
everyone takes a subway no one read
Rives in the city really well it's super
expensive the average person doesn't
have a car in the city or even a place
to park their car yeah basically and
there's no parking lots so this is a
this is a like a town thing and in and
in like a site outside of major cities
in Japan like Osaka Tokyo or whatever
majority of the country is like smaller
towns where everyone knows each other so
it's like ya know and then check this
out apparently he did this to a thousand
cards
a thousand 1000 you can even get one not
one that's why I'm like this man has no
good what kind of conversation is he
having like how he's probably gone do
you need help with your tires ma'am no
my jump the gun do you want me to lick
your [ __ ] Horace what can you sit on my
face ma'am so the thing with Japan is
like it's extremely easy to get laid if
you're an average guy because there's so
many in cells there that like ah yeah
but then like and then there's a lot of
there's there's a lot of females there
and in like if you're I don't know like
just a 5% of dudes that is just normal
and you talk to girls and you know how
to have fun and you go out like it's
yeah and they're much more liberal than
here when it comes to sex and dating and
everything and you don't flush their
tires
cuz you have a lot of weirdos that just
don't even approach women period I
wouldn't know where he got this idea I
know I did this come from and not just
that but like what do you do for a
living to afford all these tired cuz
he's replacing the tires for these women
he's gonna spare yeah they're saying
that that well yeah like it's he's
getting he's bringing his own tire to
help these women how would that work cuz
and tires don't just fit on cars like
maybe he plans it out like oh she's hot
and typed up although we can't just put
a tire on a wheel you know like all
right yeah you put a due to either need
a press or you need a bunch of [ __ ]
smooth that he's there for like an hour
Tom [ __ ] put that on
well that's why he probably thinks like
oh perfect that whole time we can you
could just have a spare it's not a
perfect fit from their trunk maybe he
doesn't even try to put it on he's just
like oh I see that you need help and
they you sparks the conversation from
there maybe or like I'll just call
someone for you or something and it
always ends poorly with the girl slap
and I'm running away you think it has to
work like once every like hundred tries
because it's like guys with cat call
right like sometimes somebody turns
around they're like oh but it didn't
work people
for this guy sometimes that's why
they're like so okay with like doing it
a hundred times because one time someone
will turn around be like oh cool this
will did it a thousand and not once they
go through no those is a one comment
that said maybe that was his endgame he
just has a fetish for women thanking him
oh yeah that's what I'm thinking like I
think that the goal for him is probably
what he gets off on has to be either the
actual slashing of the tire like
puncturing the tires because a fetish
for putting on tire though maybe it's a
think you think yeah yeah okay kinda
like the nurses who end up having like
their patients get sick because they
want to feel useful like a proxy
yeah that one yes yeah maybe they'd like
to come in to the rescue the hero's a
hero yeah and after that's done they're
like I did a good thing today mm-hmm
it's like but you slash the tire you
[ __ ] it doesn't tell that part is
hiked yeah they just ignore that part
yeah let's just completely ignore that
you actually committed the trauma and
you committed the crime or you committed
the [ __ ] up thing and then you came to
solve it it's like if you cut it you
should solve it oh no it looks like is
there a picture of it no I want to see
him too it's a picture of Joe it's like
one of those I need the news anchors and
the reporting I wanted we got Takashi a
Bokashi dude and thousand times and you
couldn't get one and not just that but
like he had already gotten in trouble
with the law for this and yet he's still
doing the same thing I'm like this was
addicted somehow there's like a lot of
high levels of thirst out there though
that's comical like this is some weird
[ __ ] but it's also extremely funny yeah
I mean think about it what country has a
vending machine where you can buy a
dirty underwear
I wanted to see those when we were there
and I did not come across a single it's
not on in the street you got to go into
you got to go into a
dirty store I came back to my apartment
in Japan once and there was a dirty
panty on my porch
was it yours no it was it was a granny
panty oh that's probably odd like
someone washing it fell down from
upstairs yeah boring story I want to go
with the other one I'm gonna go there do
you think a grandma was getting [ __ ]
buff but then she she's like oh my god
so let's come in and she let their
panties there we we found pennies in a
place that we stayed high slen Iceland
you'll do one of the doors was the
president no but I don't want to mention
with the long to because it just makes
it like weird what you knew him alone to
like the type of person it was a little
girls panties okay well I mean they
should sound like a baby behind vacation
vacation they don't left it there but it
wasn't placed in a place where you would
put your your clothes if you were
staying there was you in the drawer was
inside of a drawer of a desk with the
law uh there was a long video it was
unlocked and so we were just we were
just here like looking at somebody I
think little kids just stuff their [ __ ]
everywhere you just find that stuff I
put a sock in a lamp which part of the
lamp you could open the less of the lamp
was like a vase and then I took a sock
off and I stopped it there's like my
treasure dude my cousin oh my I told
this story before like years ago but my
cousin is poor little girl she was so
embarrassed of like her just like
starting her period that for some reason
she thought it was a good idea to stuff
her used pads in our lazy boy recliner
did it start to smell that's how we
found it why didn't she do it outside
I don't why inside of a piece of
furniture like you can't destroy the am
but evidence either it was her house oh
that's why because she's destroying the
evidence in your house how to say it's
someone else's problem now I really go
to fees house again mom so like she
probably just she didn't know it was a
very it's a scary time for girls did you
step in and help her my mom talked to
her that's good really I could relate
because I used to pick my nose and put
it under the chair I used to put on the
couch so I get it I get it
yeah you're like once you put it down
there it's gone yeah I don't deal with
like oh yeah I did the same
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]